dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here
reinforcement learning is a learning
algorithm that chooses a set of actions
in an environment to maximize a score
this class of techniques enables us to
train an AI to master video games
avoiding obstacles with a drone cleaning
up a table with a robot arm and has many
more really cool applications we use the
word score and reward interchangeably
and the goal is that over time the agent
has to learn to maximize a prescribed
reward so where should the rewards come
from most techniques work by using
extrinsic rewards extrinsic rewards are
only a half solution as they need to
come from somewhere either from the game
in the form of a game score which simply
isn't present in every game and even if
it is present in a game it is very
different for Atari breakout and for
instance a strategy game intrinsic
rewards are designed to come to the
rescue
so the AI would be able to completely
ignore the in-game score and somehow
have some sort of inner motivation to
drive an AI to complete a level but what
could possibly be the good intrinsic
reward that would work well on a variety
of tasks shouldn't this be different
from problem to problem if so we are
back to square one if we are to call a
learner intelligent then we need one
algorithm that is able to solve a large
number of different problems if we need
to reprogram it for every game that's
just a narrow intelligence so the key
finding of this paper is that we can
endow the AI with a very human-like
property curiosity human babies also
explore the world
out of curiosity and as a happy
side-effect learn a lot of useful skills
to navigate in this world later however
as in our everyday speech the definition
of curiosity is a little nebulous we
have to provide a mathematical
definition for it in this work this is
defined as trying to maximize the number
of surprises this will drive the learner
to favor actions that lead to unexplored
regions and complex dynamics in a game
so how do these curious agents fare
well quite good in Punk when the agent
plays against itself it will end up in
long matches passing the ball between
the two pedals
about bowling well I cannot resist but
quote the author's for this one the
agent to learn to play the game better
than agents trained to maximize the
clipped extrinsic reward directly we
think this is because the agent gets
attracted to the difficult to predict
flashing of the scoreboard occurring
after the strikes with a little stretch
one could perhaps say that this AI is
showing signs of addiction I wonder how
it would do with modern mobile games
with loot boxes but we'll leave that for
future work now how about Super Mario
well the agent is very curious to see
how the levels continue so it learns all
the necessary skills to beat the game
incredible however the more seasoned
fellow scholars immediately find that
there is a catch what if we sit down the
AI in front of the TV that constantly
plays new material you may think that
this is some kind of a joke but it's not
it is a perfectly valid issue because
due to its curiosity the AI would have
to stay there forever and not start
exploring the level this is the good old
definition of TV addiction talk about
human-like properties and sure enough as
soon as we turn off the TV the agent
gets to work immediately who would have
thought the paper notes that this
challenge needs to be dealt with over
time however the algorithm was tested on
a large variety of problems and it did
not come up in practice and the key
insight is that curiosity is not only a
great replacement for extrinsic rewards
the two are often aligned but curiosity
in some cases is even superior to that
this is an amazing value proposition for
something that we can run on any problem
without any additional work so curious
agents that are addicted to flashing
score screens and TVs what a time to be
alive and if you enjoyed this episode
and you wish to help us on our quest to
inform even more people about these
amazing stories please consider
supporting us on patreon comm slash to
minute papers you can pick up cool perks
there to keep your papers addiction in
check as always there is a link
to it and to the paper in the video
description thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time